so guys welcome to today's webinar on
how to make the most of performance
reviews
we are live now i hope most of the
students have joined
and others who are running late should
be able to join shortly
till then we can start off so welcome
again
and uh i'm meera singh ravath your
career coach we have jackie today as my
support partner
she'll be moderating the chat for us
thank you jackie for joining and
supporting
moving on to the next slide so before we
begin
let's get to know each other it will be
lovely if all of you can type your name
and the nanodegree that you are pursuing
and if possible your location
so that everyone gets to know each other
and can connect later directly
i always encourage all my coaches to
visit the student hub
on career online chat room every day and
leverage from the q
a that are being passed there and also
connect and network with the students
so please go ahead and type out your
details in the chat box
and let's see where do we have everyone
from i see guys from baltimore from
london
from canada i see russia from egypt
i see samuel from mexico i see
uh joanne from colombia i see zubair
from london
and who else do we have so keep keep
introducing yourself and
students y'all can pick up the names and
the nano degrees
from the chat it'll be good for you guys
to connect later
i see i see tadi from south africa
welcome everyone i see haroon from usa
all right so now we will start our
webinar while you keep introducing
yourself
now move on to the next slide quick
introduction about me
i'm currently located out of india i
have close to two and a half decade of
work experience in senior leadership
roles
for large multinational firms to focus
on bfsi
i specialize in career strategy
interviewing skills
i would request everyone to put
themselves on mute
i think jackie you can go ahead and mute
students who have forgotten to mute
themselves
uh so that way it will make sure that
everyone is able to listen i'm just
checking
for those students who are not on mute
all right
okay so
coming back to my introduction i'm
culturally astute with extensive
experience in bringing together
global stakeholders i'm known for
mentoring coaching and developing high
performance teams
with diverse capabilities and i have
developed leaders
across my tenure in previous
organizations
i'm also a certified behavior and
personality practitioner
specialized in john wiley tools so
moving on to the next slide
what are our key takeaways today
and what can we expect to gather from
this webinar
so what is there in it for me right if
you're going to give me one hour of your
time
what is it that you're going to take
away with you this slide tells you
what is there in it for all of us it's
self readable
self self explanatory we learn the
importance of performance reviews what
are the different types of performance
reviews
the role of performance review in
evaluation of employees the process
the benefits and finally the tips moving
on to the next slide
is today's agenda it's almost kind of a
mirror to the takeaways
we are going to discuss all these topics
so we will quickly move on to the actual
agenda slide so let's get everybody
engaged
we move on to our next slide which is a
poll what is more interesting way of
getting people to start
looking at the presentation and actually
contributing
please go ahead and take the poll this
is anonymous
let's see what each one of us here today
has to say about it
this poll is anonymous so feel free to
share your responses
i'm going to launch the poll now for you
guys all right
uh so here we go and i have launched
the poll the question is have you
experienced a performance review or a
performance appraisal
so it will be good to see how many of
you have actually done
and how many of you are still lucky not
to have gone through it
it anyway helps all of us to know where
we stand
so we'll just give it another 10 seconds
this was quick
i think almost everybody has responded
to it
just waiting for a few more to add
this is anonymous don't shy away just
put in whatever you have experienced
this is more to understand the
statistics by the way did you know
that uh performance reviews is not just
for people who are
already working it's also for people who
have
who are job seekers and you will learn
more about it
as we go through the other slides in
this webinar
so if you have not gone through a
performance review or an appraisal
please type that in here because that
actually gives us coaches the statistics
to build the next
webinar subjects so don't shy away go
ahead and
give your answers i'm going to give it
another
five seconds before we close the poll
all right i hope everyone has
participated and i'm not sure the ones
who don't want to respond what could be
the reason because it is quite a
harmless question
i can see just one or two of us not
yet responded but i guess in the
interest of time we are going to close
the poll
and here we go now are you guys able to
see
the results please type yes in the chat
if you are
i'm sharing the results now
are you able to see the result yes
okay lovely so we have 53 percent of the
participants who have
not yet gone through a performance
review and we have 47
who have gone through a performance
review so it will be
beneficial for both but both type of
participants
to actually go through this webinar so
let's get started now
thank you for your responses moving on
to our next slide
here is our first topic
what is a performance review so
a performance review is a regular review
of an
employee's job performance and overall
contribution to a company
it is a continuous process to secure
information necessary
for making correct and objective
decisions on employees
also known as an annual review or
employee appraisal
a performance review evaluates an
employee's achievements
and growth or lack thereof the
performance review
often includes both the core
competencies required by the
organization
and also the competencies specific to
the employee's job
the appraiser often a supervisor
or manager will provide the employee
with constructive
actionable feedback based on the
assessment
this in turn provides the employee with
the direction
needed to improve and develop in their
job companies use performance appraisals
to give
employees the big picture feedback on
their work
and to justify pay increases and bonuses
as well as determination decisions
they can be conducted at any given time
but tend to be annual semi-annual or
quarterly
so moving on to the next slide which is
importance of performance reviews so we
have a poll again
so let's see what do we have this time
all right so does a performance review
matter in career growth
i'm going to launch the poll and
feel free to take your pick it is
anonymous
i have launched the whole so does a
performance review matter and career
growth what are the options we have on
the screen
yes no maybe this is anonymous we cannot
see who has typed which answer
all we get is statistics so it will be
good to know
what your views are because then you
will be able to actually see
whatever view you had whether that was
correct based on the research that i
have done
and the slides that i'm presenting yes
please go ahead this was faster
i enjoy a lot of when all the students
participate it's really good
so we have just one or two of us yet to
participate in the poll
i'll just give it another 20 seconds
and then we should be closing this
all right so the results are pretty
pretty uh
going on to one side when i share the
results you yourself will be able to see
it
all right so just two more seconds and
i'm ending the poll
okay and now i'm going to share the
results please type yes if you're able
to see the results
whopping score of 82 percent
where students and participants feel
that yes
a performance review does matter in
career growth
and we have 18 who feel maybe the good
news is there is not a single
participant who thinks
that a performance review does not
matter in career growth
and you're absolutely right performance
reviews do matter
yeah i'm going to stop sharing the poll
now and we will move on to our next
slide
all right so what do we have on the next
slide importance of performance
appraisals
let us take a look at a few compelling
performance
management statistics and see the direct
correlation to employee engagement
you can see the source and you can see
the comment
so the link from linkedin we have
managers who received feedback on their
strengths
showed 8.9 percent greater profitability
the hr daily advisor companies who
implement regular employee feedback have
turnover rates that are 14.9 percent
lower than for employees who receive no
feedback
globe newswire says 24 of workers would
consider leaving their jobs if they have
managers that provide
inadequate performance feedback and
linkedin again says
69 percent of employees say they would
work harder
if they felt their efforts were better
recognized
moving on to the next slide the
statistics continue
again linkedin had done a survey where
they got the result
that 92 percent of respondents agreed
with the assertion
negative feedback if delivered
appropriately
is effective at improving performance
pr newswire says 63 of gen z
said they want to hear timely
constructive performance feedback
throughout the year
and 27 percent of workers strongly agree
that the feedback they currently receive
helps them to do their work
and finally 68 percent of the employees
who receive
accurate and consistent feedback feel
fulfilled
in their jobs so this should kind of
give us an
idea through statistics
what is why is performance review
important how it drives various
dimensions of our career
moving on to the next slide now reading
from the slide
the significance of a performance review
is twofold
it helps the organization to determine
the value and productivity
that employees contribute and it also
helps employees to develop in their own
roles
now performance reviews help too
here are few pointers measure and reward
performance this is a new
no brailler all the guys who chose the
answer of
yes performance review matters in career
growth you will be able to relate
to this particular point measure and
reward performance
correct it's a direct correlation many
organizations have something called spot
potential spot awards
that also gets measured managing manage
changing roles many times when your
appraisal happens when your review
happens
a lot of your potential comes out based
on what you have performed in the whole
year what additional
initiatives you have taken where you
have raised your hand to do something
which was out of the box or which was
beyond your
functional role so it helps to take a
decision on managing changing rules
for employee development improving
performance definitely and giving
employees a voice
this is a good forum for employees to be
able to give feedback to their managers
and to their management
so now moving on to the next slide which
is slide number 14.
performance reviews are also important
for five more reasons first one reading
from the slide
maintaining maintained records in order
to determine
compensation packages wage structure
salary raises second to identify
the strengths and weaknesses of
employees to place
right resource on right job
third maintain and assess the potential
present in a person for further growth
and development
fourth provider feedback to employees
regarding their performance
and related status and finally review
and retain the promotional
and other training programs moving on to
slide
next slide here is the pictorial
representation
of importance of the performance reviews
if you look at it i'm going to explain
each one of this in clockwise
for you to understand this uh better so
i am just checking if anybody is not on
mute
all right so
all right now the first one starting
clockwise
employee recognition and rewards what is
this
appraisals provide the opportunity to
recognize and reward employees
and to ensure they feel valued for the
work that they do
by monitoring performance and progress
against objectives
employees can assess whether to reward
staff with salary increases
promotions or bonuses it's also a chance
to say thank you
and to provide verbal feedback and
praise regarding any successes
highlighted
doesn't have to be financial although
money still holds considerable
importance
and salaries should be regularly
reviewed to ensure
they remain competitive and in line with
performance
simple and sincere acknowledgements
still go a long way
towards maintaining the engagement
second point new challenges and clear
objectives
so organizations with a great workplace
culture
are ones where employees feel a real
sense of belonging
they understand what the organization is
trying to achieve
are inspired by its mission and values
and recognize how their role plays a
part in achieving
overall success the discussions which
take place during appraisal meetings
will help employees to understand how
the individual objectives set for them
will play a part in the wider business
plan
so the strategy unfolds okay this helps
to give employees a sense of
ownership within the collective vision
and to empower them to achieve the
results needed
it's also a great opportunity to
regularly review
objectives and to provide ongoing
challenges
to ensure employees remain motivated by
new goals and experiences
the next point continued progression and
development
now how how does performance review help
in continued progression and development
organizations which provide clear
progression opportunities
are attractive to new recruits and are
more likely
to be able to retain talented employees
by mapping out a career path for them
regularly looking at performance
will help to identify when employees are
ready
to take on more responsibility setting
aside the time
to discuss an employee's individual
ambitions will also help the
organization
to spot and develop potential talent and
build a strong succession
pipeline in today's digital era where we
have websites like glassdoor
where anybody can go and give their
opinion
good things go also the not so good
things go there
so this is definitely going to help
performance review definitely help in
continued progression and development
next one culture of trust and openness
what is this
in today's fast-paced business world
it's more important than ever to
maintain a meaningful
two-way dialogue with employees to help
keep talented people within your
organization
one of the key enablers for achieving
employee engagement is to ensure
that employees have a voice and
performance review meetings can help to
fuel
discussion and empower staff to share
their opinions
they will feel encouraged to influence
innovation
by feeding ideas upwards and the
relationship which develops
from open communication with an
appraisal system
will help employees to feel more
able to approach and discuss any ideas
outside of these meetings as well next
point
support and training open discussions on
performance can help to identify
any problems early and provides the
opportunity to explore
positive solutions managers can look at
what additional training and support
could be provided
to enable the employee to achieve
results
which they would feel proud of high
performing employees can be supported
with further training to help them
progress to the next level
prevention of long-term dissatisfaction
this is an important one
issues can usually be nipped in the bud
before they escalate to the point of
someone
leaving if they can be raised
through appraisal meetings it is a great
opportunity for an employee
to raise any worries or concerns or to
discuss any barriers
which they feel are holding them back
taking the time to listen
to employees and address any concerns
helps to create a happier workforce
and will continue to fuel a culture of
openness
and trust now the last one supporting
staff to deliver an effective appraisal
system
for appraisals and performance
communications
to work to best effect managers need to
feel effectively equipped to provide
regular feedback
and ongoing performance management
investing in training for managers
to able to deliver effective performance
appraisals with an
authentic approach is a worthwhile
investment
maintaining a natural management style
will help them to foster
the trust and respect needed to build
open
and transparent relationships and
developing skills
such as active listening and performance
assessment
will help to ensure a constructive
appraisal system
is in place so with that we move on to
next slide
which is the actual slide types of
performance reviews so now we know what
is performance review what is its
importance it's time for us to know what
are the different types of performance
reviews
so there are various methods that are
used by managers and employers to
evaluate the performance
and they can be put into two categories
so in terms
of designing the evaluation technique
each company considers various factors
such as size of employees work schedule
goal of the company and so on whatever
method is used
it is important to select the right
method for assessing
the quality and quantity of work
performed by individuals
there are many methods of merit rating
which can be classified into two
categories
traditional and modern method this slide
is self-explanatory
and lists the types of traditional
methods for performance review
so you can see all the seven eight types
of traditional methods
which are adopted for doing a
performance review on this particular
slide
you can find you can find more
information
on each of these traditional methods
method types
on this link which i'm going to paste
now on chat
feel free to save this on your systems
and
explore it after the webinar because i'm
not going to go into the depth
of each of the traditional methods i'm
going to go
into the next slide which is modern
method and i'm going to take that
one by one so moving on to the next
slide
performance appraisal types and the
modern methods
each method of performance appraisal
has its strengths and weaknesses may be
suitable for one
organization and not suitable for
another one
as such there is no single appraisal
method
accepted and used by all organizations
to measure their employees performance
all the methods of appraisal device so
far
have been classified differently by
different authors
this slide lists out the six types of
modern methods of performance review
so moving on to the next slide which is
poll it's a pole time again all those
who joined in late
and were not able to participate in the
earlier polls here is your chance
and all those who joined in after
everyone had introduced themselves
please feel free to type out your name
and your nanodegree and your country
it will help everyone else to connect
with you guys i'm launching the poll now
and here we go um
all right which method of performance
review is more popular
traditional or modern based on your
experience please please feel free and
also based on the previous two slides
feel free to uh pick your choice
this is an anonymous poll nobody is
judging
we don't come to know which student has
picked up
which answer all we get is a statistics
so feel free to express what you think
is more popular and uh it's perfectly
all right
if you don't have an answer i wish i had
put a third option of saying
i'm not sure so if i would have put that
i'm sure there would have been a few
who would have picked up that but since
we don't have the third
option whichever comes closer to your uh
understanding or your experience please
pick that up
all right so i'll give it another 20
seconds for one minute to get
over one minute is a good time for
people to just answer a poll
i see quite a few new students who have
joined in a little later
which is good welcome to those who
joined in late all right
so now i'm going to close the polls
close this poll and share the results
please confirm with a yes in the chat if
you're able to see the result
so the question was which method of
performance review is more popular
tradition traditional or modern we kind
of have 58 percent on traditional
and 42 percent on modern as i said
different organizations
adopt different methods so depending on
what exposure we have got
in which organizations every answer is
correct
i'm going to stop sharing the polls and
we will go on to our next slide
which is um
which is on traditional
methods so we are going to deep dive in
on modern methods
we are going to deep dive into each of
the six methods
on on modern methods all right so
traditional methods of employee
engagement have divided
opinions in delivering effective results
they focus more on measuring an
employee's past performance
rather than improving future work which
is why
many organizations are adapting their
performance appraisal methods
to be more accommodating to modern
methods
let's have a brief look into the six
subtypes of modern methods of
performance reviews
so here's a close look the first one
management by
objectives this performance appraisal
method is used to match the
overarching organizational goals with
objectives of employees effectively
while
validating objectives using the smart
method
to see if the set objective was specific
measurable achievable realistic and time
sensitive
at the end of the review period which
could be quarterly half yearly or annual
employees are judged by their results
success is rewarded with promotion
and a salary hike whereas failure is
dealt with
transfer of further training this
process usually
lays more stress on tangible goals
and intangible aspects like
interpersonal skills commitment etc
are often brushed under the rug this is
ideal for
measuring the quantitative and
qualitative output for senior management
by the way did you know retail giant
like walmart uses an extensive mbo
participatory approach to manage the
performance
of its top middle and first line
managers
moving on to the next slide the next
subtype of modern method
is 360 degree feedback this appraisal
method has
five integral components like
self-appraisal
manager managerial reviews peer reviews
and subordinates appraisals and customer
or client reviews
i'll quickly take you through with one
one statement on what are these five
things in each of this so 360 degree
uh feedback will include a
self-appraisal self-appraisal
offers employees a chance to look back
at their performance
and understand their strengths and
weaknesses
managerial reviews performance reviews
done by the managers are a part of the
traditional
and basic form of appraisals these
reviews must include
individual employee ratings awarded by
the supervisors
as well as the evaluation of a team peer
reviews
as hierarchies move out of the
organizational picture
co-workers get a unique perspective on
the employees performance
making them the most relevant evaluator
these reviews help determine an
employee's ability
to work well within the team take up
initiatives
and be a reliable contributor however
friendship or animosity between peers
may end up distorting the final
evaluation results
the fourth contributor to this 360
degree type of performance review is
subordinating appraising manager
this in short form is called sam
subordinates
appraising manager this upward appraisal
component of the 360 degree feedback
is a delicate and significant step
reportees tend to have the most unique
perspective
from a managerial point of view however
reluctance or fear of retribution can
skew
appraisal results the last contributor
of 360 degree
type of performance review is customer
or
client reviews the client component of
this phase can
include either internal customers such
as use
users of product within the organization
or external customers who are not part
of the company
but interact with this specific employee
on a regular basis
customer reviews can evaluate the output
of an employee
better however these external users
often do not see the impact
of processes or policies on an
employee's
output now we move did you know
that top private organizations like rbs
sainsbury's g4s are using 360 degree
multi-rater performance
feedback to measure employee performance
moving on to the next slide slide number
22 the third subtype of modern method of
performance review
which is assessment center method
during the assessment employees are
asked to take part in social
exercises like in-basket exercises
informal discussions fact-finding
exercises
decision-making problems and role-play
and other exercises
that ensure success in a role
all right so this slide you can see
there are three components which i'm
sure all of you are reading
did you know microsoft philips and
several other organizations
use the assessment center practice to
identify
future leaders in their workforce moving
on to the next slide
behaviorally anchored rating scale
the short form of this is bars the ars
the first step in bars creation is
generation of critical incidents
that depict typical workplace behavior
the next step is editing these critical
incidents
into a common format and removing any
redundancy
after normalization the critical
instances are randomized
and assessed for effectiveness remaining
critical incidents are used
to create bars and evaluate employee
performance moving on to
next slide the la the fifth one
psychological appraisals now what are
these
qualified psychologists conduct
a variety of tests in-depth interviews
psychological tests discussions and more
to assess an employee effectively
however it is a rather slow and complex
process and the quality of results is
highly dependent
on the psychologist who administers the
procedure
specific scenarios are taken into
account while performing psychological
appraisals
for instance the way in which an
employee
deals with an aggressive customer
can be used to appraise his or her
persuasion skills behavioral response
response and much more i had covered one
webinar in the past
on emotional intelligence so if you go
on youtube
and if you try to find out and explore
emotional
intelligence udacity you will get more
information
about how to develop your emotional
intelligence
now did you know ford motors
exxon mobil procter and gamble use
psychological appraisals to test
the personality and performance of their
employees
moving on to the next slide which is the
sixth and the last type
of modern method of performance review
called human resource accounting method
so when an employee's performance is
evaluated based on cost accounting
methods
factors like unit wise average service
value
quality overhead cost interpersonal
relationships
and more are taken into account its high
dependency on the cost on benefit
analysis
and the memory power of the reviewer
is the drawback of human resources
accounting method
with that we complete all six types of
modern methods of performance review
moving on to our next slide it's poll
time again
for those who are who missed
the previous poll this is a multi-choice
question
so here we go i have launched the poll
this poll is anonymous
feel free to pick your choose and choice
what is the question
the question is what are the benefits of
a performance review
so there are six answers there please
feel free
to pick up whichever you think
appropriately
matches the question so this seems to be
um i'm getting great responses
different opinions and views which is
very very interesting
by the way the response to this poll
will also show
what kind of organization people are
working or what kind of performance
reviews they have experienced
and what outcomes they have seen in
their performance reviews
this poll is a clear indication of
experiences of individual people
so i would encourage people to go ahead
and please take this poll
because this gives an insight to each
one of us
how there are some people who have
experienced it all
and how some of us have experienced it
in bits and pieces
so i'm going to give it 10 more seconds
before i close the poll
all right and i am closing the poll
now here we go and i'll publish the
results
there you go all right this is a great
mix if you notice
44 of the participants say promotions
and transfers
25 say monitor recruitment and induction
again 44 percent say training and
development
six percent say selection validation and
44 percent say better rapport between
management and employees
whopping 50 percent say all of the above
okay so yes the answer is all of the
about
depending on the maturity of the
organization
as we mentioned different organizations
are on a different maturity curve
so if it's a very matured organization
all of this will be
the benefits that an employee will
derive and if they are
on the lesser curve then there could be
some of these
or a few of these all right so we thank
you for sharing your responses we move
on to our next slide
which is let's see now what are the
benefits
actually okay so
there are 10 benefits of performance
review here is a list of the benefits
the statistics so the statistics of a
performance review
can be used to monitor the success of
the organization's recruitment and
induction practices
so that's the first benefit the second
benefit
planning for providing training and
development
through the appraisal procedure the
supervisors
can comprehend the strengths and
weaknesses of their subordinates
which also help the hr department
to design training and development
program the third benefit
it motivates employees if supported by a
good
merit-based compensation system best
performers
get better pay and benefit packages
similarly
those employees that lag behind get
feedback accordingly
the fourth benefit it's a tool of
inspiration
performance reviews act as an
inspirational tool for the employees
because it's process of weighing up the
performance level
and the recognition system after
achieving the goal
can boost up the efficiency and
productivity level of the employees
the fifth one selection validation
performance appraisals help the
supervisors
to understand the validity and
importance of the selection procedure
the supervisors come to know the
validity and thereby the strengths and
weaknesses
of the selection process future changes
in selection methods can be made using
performance reviews the sixth benefit
improve relationship between management
group employees
after the review the employees get an
opportunity to discuss their concern
with supervisors which is not only
helpful
for resolving any grievance or dispute
but also
improves this rapport between the
management group and employees
the seventh benefit assist to enhance
employee performance
the evaluation performance needs
supervisors
to take note of insufficiencies in
employees performances
and must communicate to the respective
employees accordingly
the manager or supervisor can give
suggestions to overcome these deficits
the eighth benefit
to integrate with strategic division
one of the important purposes of
conducting a performance review
is to communicate employee goals which
are a part of the strategy
strategic vision of the organization
performance and transfers the merit
evaluation system helps to recognize
talented employees to groom them as
competent
and organization admits hard work and
accomplishment of employees
by giving promotion deputation and
transfer the last benefit
detect valued performance performers
evaluation system helps
in recognizing potential employees in
the organized employees in the
organization
at the time of taking personnel
decisions
like who will be promoted to an
influential position
or who will be laid off the employers
take the decision on the basis of
performance history
skill level and experience the review
system is also helpful for taking
inventory
of quality people in the organization
and the hr department takes the decision
to recruit new employees or upgrade the
existing workforce
moving on to the next slide components
of performance
appraisals
all right so
here are the four components of
performance appraisals that you can see
on your slide uh not four sorry uh
six communication collaboration and
teamwork
you can it's a self-explanatory readable
slide
once the components are clear the
process is quite straightforward
if you refer to the left hand side of
the slide
to understand the process it starts with
defining expectations
followed by measuring and evaluation
providing feedback based on statistical
information
ending with maintaining the record of
performance
this again plugs back objectively in
defining
future expectation moving on to the next
slide
how to prepare for a performance
appraisal many people find the review
process stressful
but a great deal of the stress and
anxiety around performance reviews
can be reduced or eliminated with proper
preparation
here are a few suggestions understand
the review process
if you have been through the process
before this may be unnecessary
but if you are in a new job or there is
a new process in place
contact human resources and find out as
much as you can
about the review process so you can be
properly prepared
don't forget to find out the review how
the review is related to compensation
and promotions
second keep a work journal a work
journal doesn't have to be fancy
it can be as simple as running to-do
list where you mark off
what you have accomplished and when
um this will help you remember your own
accomplishments over time as well as
have evidence of those
accomplishments next point do you do
your own review
if you're provided with a self analysis
worksheet fill it out honestly
if not make a list of your job
responsibilities
and conduct your own review of yourself
pay particular attention to making a
list of your accomplishments and
anticipating any feedback you may
receive
next point come up with your goals
managers
often ask about your goals for the next
year
during a performance review so take some
time
to think about it and come up with solid
goals
before you enter the review meeting so
you are not
left stammering next point prepare
feedback for your boss
depending on the format of your review
your boss may ask you
to rate his or her performance as well
take some time to formulate any feedback
or constructive criticism that you may
have
next next way of preparing drive the
discussion
before you head into your review make a
short list
of topics that you would like to cover
with your manager
your annual review is a perfect
opportunity
to talk about anything that may be on
your mind
with regard to your career trajectory
team projects budget and so on
take the opportunity to make the review
work for you
the last point research salary data
jackie had delivered an amazing webinar
on salary negotiations you can find this
on youtube and also on the students hub
on the right hand side
go through that webinar if you plan to
ask for a raise
take the time to research average
salaries for your position
location and work experience so that
you have data to back up your request
moving on to the next slide here
are the tips for writing your
performance evaluation
all right so i am just looking at the
slide yes your other
so this slide covers tips for writing
performance reviews
the exact structure of your annual
performance review will depend
on the areas your leaders want to assess
self-evaluation tips are a useful
framework
to structure your own self-assessment
when it comes
time to completing your review so
starting with the first one
assess achievement of objectives you
will likely have set yourself goals
to achieve this year in collaboration
with your manager
whether you met your targets or you went
off track
this is the time to objectively document
the outcomes
next point describe your accomplishments
accomplishments are more general than
objectives
and it's an excellent space to
demonstrate skills improvements
and new challenges you took on all right
the next one is demonstrate behavior of
company core
values organizations will typically
outline three to five core behaviors
that are important to the company
culture some
organizations call it values and
everyone's ways of working are connected
to the values
or behaviors when evaluating yourself
on these core values make sure to
illustrate how you demonstrate the
behaviors
in your work and not what is an
intrinsic personality trait
for this you will have to keep a log of
incidents
so that you can recall what behavior
did you actually deliver in those
situations
next one identify areas for improvement
all of us always have scope of improving
right so make sure that you make a note
of that and bring it up in your review
being critical of your own performance
is difficult
but we all go off track at times
take responsibilities for areas where
you felt short
but focus on the steps you took or can
take to correct these in future
the next step suggest areas for
professional development
everybody has skills that they can
develop further
and organizations often have programs in
place
to support these the performance review
is a great time
to bring up skill gaps that you want to
close
and to discuss with your manager how to
go about that
the next tip define your job and role
there is no way to evaluate your
performance without a clear description
of your job if you already have one
keep it handy while composing your self
evaluation
if you don't know where to find this or
if your job description has
changed now is the time to write one
it does not have to be a massive
document
define the major responsibilities of
your job
from the consistent requirements to the
long term projects
it's your job so even if other
colleagues
share your title make sure to review
or establish the specifics that make
your position yours do this even if it
is not a requirement for your review
if you don't the rest of your evaluation
will not be persuasive
or effective the last benefit the last
step
align with your manager before beginning
your review
ask your manager or whoever is
responsible
for your review how the self evaluation
will be used
you would not write anything else for
work without knowing your target
audience right
this should be no different once you
know your role
and the purpose of your self-evaluation
you will be ready to start writing the
performance review
in the right state now
um here is a good article for
referencing later to
understand the performance review
examples i'm posting the link
on the chat right now for all you live
participants
as a takeaway please pick it up from
chat and go through it
later on moving on to the next slide
sample action verbs a ready list for you
to leverage
from don't you think it's a great
interesting slide
how simple words can actually make very
powerful and impactful story and
narrative
and statements i often tell people
we know that we have the skills in our
mind but we sometimes don't get the
right words
all these lists of these kind will give
you the right words to the thoughts in
your mind
feel free to take a screenshot of uh
this slide
uh as a ready retina for yourself anyway
this this will be
uh uploaded on youtube as well so you
can pick it up at that time
also moving on to the next slide
examples of performance review questions
all right and this is the last agenda
item
so what do we have
let's see key appraisal questions to
prepare for
see it's difficult to know the exact
questions you will be asked during your
performance appraisal because
the questions will depend on the company
your particular job the industry
whether it's a small business or a large
one
the size of the i.t department how long
you have been with the company
and so on that should not prevent you
from preparing ahead of time however
because you can at least review a list
of general appraisal questions
start with these list of six critical
performance appraisal questions
to get you thinking about more specific
questions you might get
asked and how you will answer them so
the first question that you see on the
slide
how did you do on the goals set for you
during your last performance appraisal
so you might hope that your manager has
been paying attention to your efforts
throughout the previous year
but that probably hasn't been the case
when 53 of employers admit
they don't track improved productivity
the onus is on you as the employee
to document your achievements and
progress
as you prepare for your performance
review think
back to the goals that was set those you
accomplished
and your progress on those you did not
be ready to explain if there are goals
you did not accomplish
but you made good progress on also
consider the progress made on goals
that was set for your team for those
goals
that were not reached were they possibly
unrealistic
if so why the second question
what was the biggest achievement this
year now this is a very interesting
question
your performance appraisal is your
opportunity to draw attention to your
track record over the past year
both regarding your goals and regarding
your achievements
so do not assume your manager will
know or remember your accomplishments
instead be ready to point them out
prior to performance appraisal pull
together
any documentation you might need to show
your recent achievements include
accomplishments related to your specific
role within the company but also any
that happened outside of your work maybe
you joined the board of an industry
organization
for example or contributed a guest post
to a blog
or maybe represented your company in a
webinar
perhaps you earned an online
certification during the previous year
that makes you more knowledgeable at
your current job or positions
you do to do more if you don't already
do so
get into the habit of documenting your
accomplishments large and small
throughout the year
you will find it's much easier to be
ready for your next performance
appraisal
when you don't have to dig through old
files or emails
to try and remember just what did you do
in the last 12 months the third question
what are your short and long term goals
with the companies
and for your career beyond the specific
goals you and your
manager will lay out for the year ahead
you might also be asked about your own
goals
if so be ready to answer questions like
these in a way that demonstrates your
desire
to learn to grow both in your career and
also in your company
consider the new skills you want to
learn and why do your homework and have
a list of technologies
or content you want to master through
online certifications during the year
ahead
discuss your plan with your manager
emphasizing that you're pursuing
this additional certification in part so
you can take on new roles and
responsibilities at work
add more value to the organization and
help you achieve short and long term
goals
as part of your performance review
preparation make a list of your short
and long term goals
make use of that time to check in on
your career progress
while doing so include both professional
and personal goals
as well as timelines for achieving them
build your allies and champions through
this particular question
fourth question what has been your most
challenging aspect of your work
this past year and why
now i'm going to just cover this in the
interest of time and then we will move
on
so what has been the most challenging
aspect of your work this past year
a question like this can be a nice seed
into discussing any courses
you would like to take to benefit your
career
perhaps you were challenged by changing
dynamics
within the technology department that
shifted job roles
around and now you are at the
disadvantage
because you don't know enough about a
certain coding language
or best practice meaning now is the time
to learn it maybe you are challenged by
lack of
teamwork and communication issues
meaning
a team building program might be in
order so use this question
as an opportunity to actually spell out
what kind of training and development
can you seek
as a support from your line manager the
fifth question let me quickly cover it
which parts of your job do you most or
least enjoy
when you're answering a question like
this position yourself in the best
possible light
saying you most enjoy your coffee breaks
will fail to impress your manager while
saying you most enjoy the challenge of
learning new skills
and taking on new duties will make your
manager's day
conversely if you have concerns about
your role or the organization
in light of recent or impending changes
or
you are struggling to get along with a
co-worker be
prepared to discuss these types of
difficult topics
in an objective way possibly
by writing down questions or talking
points
ahead of time the last question in what
ways might you contribute more to the
company
very very important question it will
come to you in some or the other shape
or form
if you would like to take on more
responsibilities play a lead role
on a team or get a promotion use a
question like this
to seek into demonstrating your
enthusiasm for doing more
do your research ahead of time to
determine what the needs might be
and how they dovetail with your career
goals
is there an opportunity to learn machine
learning in advance of changes
in your organization is your company
changing over to cloud computing
and somebody needs to master microsoft
azure
is cyber security a concern and no one
has the skill set to tackle the issue
heads on
don't wait for your manager to assume
you want to take on or do more be
open about your willingness to do so and
point out
that you can master the skills needed
and save the organization the time
and money required to hire someone new
for that role even if the questions
about
are not the exact same questions you
will be
asked they hit on the major issues your
manager will probably want to address
during your performance review you will
be much better prepared
for the specific questions that come up
if
you review and prepare for the general
questions about
and honestly evaluate your own
performance prior to
the meeting now here are the
key takeaway resource links
it's a page full of resource links and i
am
pasting them on the live chat for all
the live participants
please go ahead and take them all this
is one of the perks of attending live
webinar
okay so feel free to pick them up
uh these will also be uploaded on the
youtube
under the even description so those who
have not been able to attend the live
webinar
when they are watching the recording
below the recording is the even
description
and in the even description all of these
will be
uploaded i hope all of you have picked
up these resources
all of them will give you complete idea
depth into whatever we have discussed
today moving on to the next slide
for the credit and the research that i
did to land this pack for you guys
so a lot of research guys go into
preparing for a webinar
and we coaches actually go through so
many websites pick up the key points for
you
to make sure that we bring in synopsis
within this 45 minutes
to make the most for you now the next
section q a
the most awaited section the the webinar
cannot be
completed unless we give some time to
our students to ask
some questions which they may have on
their mind so please feel free
to uh to
to ask away your questions please
i don't know what i did but uh my chat
went away so this always happens
with me i keep pressing some buttons and
something else happens
all right uh
jackie you may have to help me today
because i
think i pressed some button which uh
changed the view
that's okay i can't see any questions at
the moment in the chat room so this is
your opportunity
all in attendance to um just raise
whatever's on your mind
uh into in relation to this webinar on
your performance reviews so any
you can questions on chat if you want or
you can even uh unmute yourself and ask
please go ahead
[Music]
hi is that tosaku
please feel free to type in
or has mira done such a fantastic job
that nobody has
any questions to raise oh okay great
we have a question has come in from
ann losh apologies if i pronounce your
surname incorrectly anne um
and her question is how can you approach
an employer that is overdue for giving a
performance review
our small company was bought by someone
else two years ago
and the boss still has not given any
reviews
so that's in from anne all right so and
if your company
has any target operating model or if
there is a particular
uh operating procedure or if there is
any compliance if you have access to any
such
thing you may first want to go through
and see whether they had
spelled out that there will be a
performance review if it is mentioned in
your appointment letter
there has to be some place where this
component has to be explicitly mentioned
if it is available in writing in any
document
of any kind of which is available to the
employees
you could use that as a reference
material and raise this with your line
manager saying
when i joined the company in my
appointment letter i did have this one
of the clauses
but i haven't experienced it once and i
understand there are many benefits of a
performance review
so it will be great if we could have a
chat even if it's
informal and not a very formal one
because i would like to grow and develop
myself
get your feedback and also get a broader
vision
and strategy of the company so that that
i can contribute more
so in this way you will be able to kind
of push your employer
to answer what is the reason that they
have not conducted a performance review
if at all that was a part of the
appointment altogether and the target
operating model of the organization
and what are the challenges that they're
having in the least
at least you will come to know what is
the vision what is the strategy
what are the goals so it's like half
battle one and that's how you will have
to keep persuading
your manager i hope that was helpful
i can see ebo has asked a question is it
okay to ask a potential employer what
model they use for performance reviews
it's a very interesting uh question ebo
yes of course you can in a friendly
manner over the coffee break talk to hr
department staff
rather than asking if you have a good
rapport with your line manager
you can go ahead and ask your line
manager too in fact you can give a
reference so that it doesn't look like
condensed ending
you can just say i attended a webinar on
performance reviews
and uh it was shared with us that there
are multiple
ways in which performance reviews are
made it would be interesting to know
which one do we use
because when we attend webinars we will
be able to contribute to the statistics
on the polls
always give a good reason for asking a
question
when you're trying to deep dig into
somebody else's functional delivery so
it does not kind of put them into an
apprehension
and it actually opens them to help you
so it depends on how you ask the
question
but you can definitely ask the question
okay
i see there is one more question
do we have the do we have the access to
this ppt presentation deck
it will be only on the you youtube
available but if the deck is not
available
yeah i see saku nelson has asked a
question
can the performance review also be a
part of first time interview process
the performance they won't call it
performance review but they will
bring in elements of performance review
into the
interview process and that is why it
becomes a selection validation benefit
in the interview procedure so the
questions
which will be asked in your interview
process they will be
directly related to your performance
delivery
you need to be mindful when the question
is being asked to you
to be able to tag it and categorize it
is this a performance delivery related
question or
is it you know a knowledge related
question
so yes a performance related questions
can be
guys into interview process in a
different shape or form
i see nsk has asked a question would it
be wise to address concerns and reasons
related to recent layoffs which happened
from the same team
during a one-on-one review session with
the line manager
how to navigate such a situation so
um would it be wise to address concerns
and reasons
so are you asking this as a line manager
or
are you asking this as one of the team
members
because the answer will depend on that
okay so you are a team member and you
are saying that if there have been
a few team members who have got laid off
or furloughed
whether it is a good thing to bring up
with the line manager so
honestly if you ask me i have always had
good uh
alignment with my line managers with my
supervisors it all
boils down to what kind of rapport
alignment understanding credibility
goodwill and tenure that you have spent
in the organization
this life is all about what have you
contributed
before you ask for something in return
so if your alignment
and if your credibility and of your
goodwill is on that curve
there is absolutely no problem in in
having
a conversation with your line manager
and communicating it in the right manner
is the main thing how you ask the
question
will decide how open your line manager
will be
in actually sharing what the challenges
were
and you can even say that i would like
to really understand
for my own stability for my own growth
for my own development
what are the things that i should
continue doing right
so that i am able to make a difference
and not form the part of the team where
they have got laid off
so it all depends on your alignment and
how you ask the question
i hope that was helpful yeah
the link of the youtube will come to you
to school
uh through udacity all of you
who have registered for the webinar will
get
an email from udacity sharing the link
of the uh of the webinar
so you will get it maybe within a day or
two i'll take one last question in the
interest of the time
the question is a startup that wanted to
employ me
after a half year probation period
suddenly refused when i told that i have
got a newborn child in spite of the fact
that i am a man
how should i answer a similar family
related question on my next job
interview
okay so these are very challenging times
victor
and uh due to pandemic a lot of things
have changed for a lot of organizations
it's not just related to your situation
or your case in particular
it's overall the situation and the
pandemic which is causing
the issue if if i may say this is a more
personal question
i would request you to book a one-on-one
coaching session
with any one of our coaches including me
or jackie or anyone you wish to
and we can definitely help you answer
this question in more
detail all right now um
with that i think this was lovely all
the audience were amazing
thank you everyone for joining the
webinar and making this webinar so
active and engaging you are a great
audience thank you for joining hope to
see you
in the next webinar again till then take
care
stay safe bye